[Musique]
m
c'est donc l'heure de notre débat sur
les jeux olympiques et la candidature de
paris pour les jo de 2024 on va parler
de ses jo avec michael et me d'euros qui
est à mes côtés de téléphiles bonjour et
pour évoquer cette candidature nous
avons bien sur ce plateau des sportifs
ou des élus qui vont pouvoir évoquer
cette candidature il ya marie claire
restoux bonjour ancien judokate
championne olympique en 1996 oui tout à
fait moi j'ai la particularité d'avoir
les deux casquettes puisque je suis une
ancienne sportive est élu a vite la
vraie en charge des sports louis radius
est aussi à nos côtés alors pour lui
c'est tout récent les jeux olympiques
puisque c'était lors des jo de rio au
niveau des paralympiques avec une
médaille de bronze à la clé sur 1500 m a
fait une très belle médaille de bronze
prévu mais là le pense qu'on a suivi et
puis à nos côtés si alexandre joly qui
conseillait départementale des yvelines
7e vice président en charge des sports
et c'est pour ce à quoi bon jour
évoquées notamment avec nous les les
différents sites yvelinois qu'ils ont
été
du coup pris pour justement cette
candidature de paris 2024 avant
d'évoquer plus précisément cette
candidature on va juste peut-être pour
les gens qui nous regardent à voir la
vie de sportif sur ce que représente des
jeux olympiques dans une carrière le le
poids justement d'une discipline pour
pour les jo et le travail aussi que cela
implique marie claire pour vous les jeux
olympiques c'était court en 1996 mais je
crois qu'en 1996 ou en 2016 ça reste le
graal pour tous les sportifs qui ont la
chance de pratiquer une discipline
olympique je crois que c'est un peu
l'aboutissement d'une carrière on
s'entraîne pendant quelques années voir
pendant plus de dix ans pour pour
décrocher une médaille olympique et
quand c'est le titre on est encore plus
content je crois que avec un petit peu
plus de recul puisque moi j'ai gagné il
ya vingt ans je m'aperçois aujourd'hui
que sané ça n'a pas été qu'une
expérience sportive
ça a été une expérience qui m'a
construite qui construit la personnalité
qui fait qu'après dans la vie on est
voilà ce qu'on est c'est une très très
belle expérience c'est très difficile à
décrire en quelques mots parce que c'est
en termes d'émotion incroyable c'est le
monde qui se réunit en un seul endroit
sur quinze jours on croise des gens
incroyables
dans une dans une ambiance à la fois de
compétition mais aussi de fraternité
partagée village olympique est un
endroit incroyable où se côtoient des
langues étrangères de toutes sortes donc
c'est vraiment une très très belle
aventure et c'est aussi pour le pays qui
a la chance d'accueillir les jeux
olympiques à la fois une expérience mais
je pense que c'est aussi une opportunité
économique est très intéressante gladius
c'est vraiment le graal vraiment cette
compétition pour la tête de haut niveau
abbas est un aboutissement c'est un
enrichissement personnel et c'est
vraiment le graal comme disait marie
claire et derrière derrière ces deux ans
pour moi de préparation à travers trois
ans où on pensait qu'on pense à cette
échéance c'est une convention qui a rien
à voir avec les championnats nous le
championnat d'europe c'est vraiment à un
poil au dessus et c'est surtout
l'université d'universalité pardon où
tous les athlètes peuvent se côtoyer où
on peut se retrouver avec toutes les
disciplines c'est ça qui intervient
intéressant pour moi est aujourd'hui là
je reviens des des jeux de rio brandi un
terme en termes d'enrichissement
personnel c'est à dire que je dois
rencontrer beaucoup de personnes mes
amis éthiopien mais canadien parce que
j'ai vécu deux ans au canada aussi et
j'ai retrouvé mes entraîneurs de
l'époque et surtout chez j'ai pu
participer à un échange interculturel et
sportif avec visite d'une favela ce
fabuleux de judo et c'est ça aussi c'est
la transmission des valeurs voilà
transmission des valeurs ça dépasse le
cadre sportif les jaunards moi je
vraiment j'avais dit à la direction
technique de pouvoir après ma confession
pouvoir m'investir un peu sur le terrain
et pouvoir rencontrer les cariocas et
d'échangés autour autour d'une pratique
sportive en l'occurrence il n'y avait
pas d'association at éthique donc je me
suis associé avec les judokas et
derrière derrière il y avait il y avait
il y avait plein de jeunes qui sont qu'
on puisse se mélanger sur cette activité
et derrière il ya beaucoup à apprendre
aussi sur les politiques puisque là-bas
il insère les des personnes en fonction
de leur classe sociale celle qui mélange
les différentes classes sociales alliés
au liban leur fabuleuse et j'ajouterai
une petite différence entre un
championnat du monde et les jeux
olympiques
même si finalement on retrouve les mêmes
adversaires
ce qui différencie c'est que le les
répercussions d'une médaille olympique
n'ont rien à voir avec la répercussion
d'une médaille mondiale c'est-à-dire que
quand vous êtes champions olympiques ou
paralympiques
vous êtes connu et reconnu du grand
public ce qui n'est pas le cas quand
vous êtes le numéro 1 de votre
discipline champions du monde et
champions du monde dans le dans le monde
dans la famille du judoka ou dans la
famille de l'athlétisme
vous êtes champion olympique voilà ça
ç'a dépassé fonds frontières là et il ya
une espèce de reconnaissance du monde
de monsieur madame tout le monde du
monde politique du monde public que vous
n'avez pas voilà et qui à la fois très
intéressant mais qu'il faut apprendre à
canaliser on l'a vu avec lui radius on a
juste avant d'arriver sur ce plateau
puisqu'il ya plein de gens qui sont venu
vous saluer juste après votre
performance alexandre joly en tant que
spectateur
vous aimez le sport mais on voit que
c'est pas les mêmes émotions si qui que
l'on vit au travers de ses athlètes au
moment des jeux olympiques païenne
dramaturgie extraordinaire je crois
qu'ils l'ont très bien racontée et
puissant aussi un mouvement d'humanité
extraordinaire les jeux olympiques c'est
complètement à part ils ont raison mais
y compris pour les spectateurs et les
citoyens j'ai eu la chance d'aller comme
spectateur à quelques jeux olympiques
j'ai la chance d'aller souvent sur les
stades c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose
une ambiance une électricité une
dramaturgie et puis des mouvements
humains extraordinaire et carlin la
famille à tout ce qu'on reconnaît qu'ils
ont eu la médaille mais c'est une
famille les olympiens tous ceux qui ont
participé aux jeux olympiques s'appelle
entre les olympiens et on s'aperçoit
qu'ils aient une véritable fraternité
alors on va maintenant qu'on a un peu
posé les bases de ce que c'était les
jeux olympiques on va peut-être pouvoir
parler maintenant de cette candidature à
proprement parler de paris 2024 qui se
retrouve donc face à los angeles et face
à budapest
rome s'étant retiré encore
officiellement de la candidature donc
plus que 2 face à paris pour cette
candidature des géo 2024 on va parler
d'abord de l'intérêt sportif évidemment
parce que quand on parle de jeux
olympiques c'est le développement
sportif ça permet de mettre en avant des
sports qu'on a peut-être pas l'habitude
de voir déjà l'habitude et puis il ya
tout ce qui va être mise en place avant
pour permettre de voir des athlètes
français briller dans ces jeux
olympiques et ça c'est important aussi
pour le développement du sport et de
tous les sports olympiques en france je
crois que quel que soit le pays qui
accueillera les jeux en 2024 certains se
prépare déjà
étant donné que c'est une tapée un
objectif forcément derrière les
fédérations sportives s'organisent pour
essayer de préparer les équipes à toutes
ces échéances à venir donc c'est
évidemment un la locomotive qui qui
entraîne l'ensemble du mouvement sportif
vers cet objectif là une seule médaille
d'or pour la grande bretagne par exemple
en 96 27 lors des derniers jo à rio cet
été c'est vraiment voilà le sport de
haut niveau ils ont réussi à le
développer est ce que nous on peut avoir
la même chose ici en france si on
organisait géo en 2024 alors
je sais pas si on peut répondre en ces
termes la force est de constater que de
passer d'une médaille à 27 et il a dû se
passer quelque chose et des décisions
ont été prises je n'ai pas l'analyse de
ce fait là savoir si l'on investit
démesurément dans des équipements si
l'on investit dans des entraîneurs qui
sont allés chercher les meilleurs aux
quatre coins du monde je sais pas
répondre à cette question en tout cas
les anglais de tout temps eu cette cette
appétence pour le sport à tel point que
le sport est complètement intégré dans
le système scolaire ce qui est beaucoup
moins vrai chez nous même si moi à titre
personnel j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on est
encore un petit peu plus de sport à la
fois à l'école au collège et au lycée
les anglais ont déjà ça est ce que le
fait d'avoir les jeux à paris en 2024
fera qu'on aura davantage de médailles
en 2024 c'est difficile de répondre mais
davantage de sportifs peut-être d'avant
sa tâche de sportifs il faut qu'ils se
qualifient puisque je rappelle que pour
les jeux olympiques des critères de
sélection voilà il ya des critères de
sélection très précieux j'espère être
des plus beaux coups plus envie en tout
cas moi je suis je ne suis plus je ne
m'entraîne plus donc je ne peux pas
répondre à cette question mais peut-être
que que tu peut être pas si on a le 13
septembre ce sera le 13 septembre ali
main qu'on aura 2017 voilà qu'on aura
savoir si on a les jeux c'est surtout
derrière la préparation durant six sept
ans auprès des jeunes donc c'est à dire
développement de l'offre sportive
développer la pratique sportive au sein
de la région ile-de-france de la france
et du département des yvelines avec je
crois que l'on parlera tout à l'heure
des sites d'accueil
dans le département mais c'est à
travailler sur sur la jeune génération
qui vont regarder ces jeux qui m'ont
pratiquer certains disciples porte il
est surtout pour ceux qui rentrent dans
des pôles espoirs ou des pôles france
aujourd'hui c'est la génération de
demain de 2024 qui pourra préparer avec
peut-être plus de moyens si on a les
jeux de mains les politiques devront
peut-être prendre des décisions est là
c'est alexandre joly qui va peut-être
devoir répondre pour les policiers je
voudrais ajouter qu en fait toutes les
collectivités participent un peu à ça
parce que moi je suis un bon exemple je
suis issue d'une toute petite commune au
fin fond de la charente j'ai commencé
dans un tout petit club donc toutes les
communes de france et de navarre quelque
part participent à la formation des
jeunes qui peut-être demain seront
champions olympiques trouvé tout à fait
d'ailleurs on s'en aperçoit sur les
dernières manifestations puisque dans
les avantages qu à la france elle a
organisé ces derniers temps des
compétitions de haut niveau mondial avec
une une fabuleuse réussite donc on a
bien vu qu'à chaque fois qu'il y avait
dans un sport une vitrine extraordinaire
et bien les clubs de se dé dans nos
villes étaient jadis surchargé de
nouvelles demandes d des enfants pour
venir alors quand une équipe de france
est concernée que ce soit le hand que ce
soit le foot c'est ce que le basket on
voit bien les équipes qui marchent
derrière un champion comme il ya 20 ou
30 ans tout le monde voudrait ressembler
à un michel jazy alami moon là
maintenant on est passé sur d'autres
sports mais je crois que c'est
effectivement à un accélérateur et à
partir du moment où il y à des citoyens
qui veulent pratiquer ce sport
les élus sont
je crois que c'est c'est quand même
normalement leur raison d'être au
service des citoyens et on doit mettre
les équipes en place plus il y a deux
personnes qui sont dans un sport puis a
de chances qu une émergence de champion
on en parlait ce matin d'ailleurs dans
un débat sur le sport il ya des
disciplines qu'ils vont rentrer au
programme olympique je pense notamment à
l' escalade nul doute que les clubs
d'escaladé risque de connaître dans les
mois les années à venir une
recrudescence de pratiquants parce que
ceux qui ont une petite appétence pour
l'escaladé on se dit ah tiens maintenant
l'escaladent est aux jeux olympiques ça
peut être un objectif pour moi une bonne
nouvelle mi-septembre l'année prochaine
ça peut aussi aider je pense que ce sera
un coup d'accélérateur à coup de boost
seulement voilà un coup d'accélérateur
les y aura une bonne nouvelle bajeux j'y
crois nous y croyons tous sur ce plateau
alors on va peut-être justement parlé de
dd site alexandre qui ont été choisis
avec son joli pour notamment dans les
yvelines il ya donc le golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le golf a fait
son entrée aux jo de rio y sera là aux
jo de 2024 et puis il y aura la ryder
cup avant qui est dans quelque chose 18
quelque chose qui parle plus dans les
pays anglo saxons mais ça fait partie
des quatre épreuves les plus télévisés
les plus regardés 100 millions de
personnes vêtues ça là bas aux états
unis
ya donc la colline d'elancourt et
ombrelles dans le dans le vélo avec le
vtt hommes et femmes il y aura le
vélodrome évidemment qu'ils étaient
prévus pour paris 2012 mais qui va être
du coup quand même servir si ça se passe
bien pour paris 2024 et la piste de bmx
aussi qui va servir pour les
compétitions de bmx y aura aussi des
épreuves de pentathlon moderne et puis
aura château de versailles l'écrin du
château de versailles qui va servir à la
fois pour les sports équestres pour le
patron et peut-être si tout se passe
bien aussi pour un petit passage avec
les compétitions de cyclisme sur route
c'est vraiment un faire-valoir aux
abords ça correspond à notre département
qui avec un certain nombre départements
de la couronne que ce soit les
hauts-de-seine comme que connaît ma
voisine et avec lesquels on travaille
régulièrement ce sont des départements
où il ya des romans de sportifs et où il
ya énormément de sites et je crois que
le vélo dans le département des yvelines
de là va traverser la vallée de
chevreuse un dimanche matin vous verrez
que bon le cheval du côté de rambouillet
et puis ça sans oublier le champ de
courses de maison la fille était un
simple et puis le golf le golf national
de saint-quentin qui qui fait partie des
fleurons au niveau mondial pour le sport
et puis en même temps il y à aussi
j'allais dire on n'a pas eu les jeux
olympiques que l'on qui ont été gagnés
par londres alors faut avouer que ce
moment on était très contrarié faut
avouer qu'ils organisaient de beau jeu
soyons sport mais il avait été promis un
certain nombre d'investissements dans le
domaine du sport et saint quentin et
bien la résultante de promesses qui ont
été faites en disant même si après les
jeux olympiques il y a besoin qu'on
avait l'autre rom qui soit digne des
résultats que épisode double nos de nous
nos sportifs et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le vélodrome de saint quentin
ixis
on est déjà prêt dans les yvelines pour
accueillir ces jeux olympiques de 2020
dans les avantages que l'on a et je
crois que les personnes qui sont mes
côtés pour conforter cette analyse c'est
qu'on a une chance extraordinaire c'est
qu'on a déjà un certain nombre d'écrans
qui peuvent accueillir le sport je parle
du stade de france on parle de de saint
quentin qui a été refait complètement
pour la ryder cup
par exemple alors il ya d'autres
endroits qui eux peuvent être multi
sports comme bercy le génie le grand
palais le aussi pour les scream et puis
versailles enfin j'imagine le
réalisateur de télévision moi je ferai
ça passe gens dormir est déjà plus je
serai en train de regarder quel angle
est le meilleur et là on relit
absolument tout c'est dire l'intérêt des
jeux olympiques est aussi de faire
découvrir un pays de faire découvrir une
culture et visait les gens à oui mais
c'est un cadeau extraordinaire je crois
qu'on peut aborder les jeux olympiques
sous toutes les facettes économique
social huet face je veux dire c'est
c'est à mon avis c'est extraordinaire un
moment où il ya de la morosité c'est un
souffle d'espoir fabuleux je dirais que
les jeux olympiques sont son créateur d'
enthousiasme parce que en fait on n'a
pas gagné 2012 et j'en connais quelque
chose puisque j'étais membre fondateur
de la candidature à l'époque le seul
équipement qui était nouvel équipement
prévu qu'on a réalisé celle vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et conquis on
espère bien qu'ils va servir à en 2024
on n'y croit très fort on a cet atout là
en france c'est que dans les yvelines
vous êtes prêts en région parisienne on
est prêt il manque très peu
d'équipements il manque la piscine le
centre le centre nautique piscine et
puis le village des athlètes
et puis le village presse
donc en fait il manque très peu de
choses et
par le passé il ya de nombreuses
candidatures qui ont construit des
équipements magnifique et puis
finalement ces équipements après on le
retrouve pas d'utilisation et donc il
reste qu'on appelle des éléphants blancs
donc des grands équipements qui sont qui
se meurt et qui restent inutilisés on
n'est pas dans ce cas-là en france sur
la carte on n'y aura pas de gâchis c'est
situe à 400 existant en fait des
infrastructures existantes sur le
territoire national et moi pour pour
rejoindre c'était aussi on a une chance
extraordinaire on a un patrimoine
culturel et historique français est
d'associer la pratique sportive ou le
sport et qui sont des valeurs de
l'olympisme à notre culture et au
patrimoine historique de château de
versailles qui va accueillir
l'équitation et le pentathlon bas c'est
grandiose et je pense que les attaques
qui vont évoluer sur sur ces sites mon
être sentir grandi et pour les
spectateurs aussi d'associer la visite
du château et d'aller à la rencontre des
gens qui pratiquent l'équitation ça va
être et puis louis ça permettra aussi
mettre un gros coup de projecteur même
si on le voit avec nos impôts nos jeux
olympiques de rio on progresse aussi en
termes de diffusion c'est pour les jeux
paralympiques lequel faisait partie
baissa ça permet aussi de mettre en
valeur aussi tous ces sportifs
paralympiques qu' on n'a pas forcément
malheureusement l'habitude de voir le
restant de l'année oui bah là pour cette
année la france télévisions a fait plus
de cent heures de retransmissions c'est
historique et ça a très bien marché
puisque il ya 14 millions de
téléspectateurs sur une dizaine de jours
qui est un pic à 3 millions les
week-ends derrière la les jeux de 2020
avec au japon à tokyo ça va rajouter
encore une couche et si on a les jeux en
2024 derrière toutes les chaînes
nationales vont pouvoir retransmettre ça
et communiqués sur sur les valeurs du
parlant piste mais sur sur le sportif
parce que encore une fois la tête
paralympiques et parent tient s'entraîne
comme à la tête valide je tenais à le
dire ici et avec les mêmes conditions
d'entraînement et je pense que l'impact
sera grandiose et comme il ya à rio il
ya eu 2 d'énormes retombées j'ai pu le
voir ça va être que positif point aussi
sur le l'aspect financier évidemment
parce qu'on parle beaucoup de la passion
parle beaucoup du sport mais c'est quand
même le nerf de la guerre le mental
c'est davantage la candidature de la
france je crois que pour toutes les
candidatures qui était jusqu'à
maintenant on parlait de sommet
extraordinaire a rajouté la les sommes à
rajouter sont principalement comme vient
de le rappeler marie claire des sous sur
les infrastructures donc ça sera du
bien-être y compris pour nos populations
quand les jeux seront iront vers
d'autres d'autres horizons donc moi je
ne vois que des avantages
et puis en même temps on n'a pas eu les
jeux qui marqué le centenaire de la
création des jeux olympiques brand enfin
un petit cocorico c'est quand même un
français qui a relancé en fin de
coubertin qui était très connu dans la
vallée de chevreuse à l'église de
chevreuse un tableau l'intérieur peu de
personnes le savent qu'ils étaient
peints par pierre de coubertin et on
invite les gens à les voir du coup dans
cette église le monde entier en 2024
s'entend après la rénovation des
occasions
ce serait ce serait un symbole très
intéressante mais maintenant il faut
voilà il faut convaincre ses parents
sont ainsi retombées économiques nous on
est non je pense que c'est pas un
fantasme toujours à inscrire de londres
9 milliards vous pensez que ça peut
rapporter autant la france semble oui
j'en suis convaincu oui d'autant qu' à
moindre frais veille à mon avis beaucoup
moins ils ont ils ont eu beaucoup de
grosses infrastructures à faire à
londres mais londres a été métamorphosé
après les après jeux olympiques années
80 les friches industrielles tout on n'a
pas ce travail là à faire mais on a un
travail d'amélioration des
infrastructures ayant quand même du
travail et qui restera positif pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens donc je
trouve que c'est une bonne utilisation
à tous points de vue vous êtes contre
les eaux les jus aux sceptiques vraiment
qu'ils sont contre les géo qui pensent
que ça coûte trop cher c'est ici que du
positif finalement les légions il ne
faut pas regarder ce que ça coûte en
investissement il faut regarder ce que
ça va rapporter c'est ça qui est le
risque le risque le risque est moindre
quand vous demandiez tout à l'heure quel
est l'intérêt de la france et gagné
pourquoi la france plutôt qu'un autre
pays c'est que le risque y compris pour
l'est les le comité olympique rappelez
vous à chaque fois au dernier moment
est-ce que le ça devait être fini à
temps est-ce que les bains la non le
problème il n'y a plus ce problème là
est-ce que ils seront assez d'argent
pour faire après les jeux paralympiques
c'était la discussion ben là il n'y a
pas de problème moi vous avez de frais
avec des recettes kim que maintenant on
arrive quand même à maîtriser ça veut
dire que la marge est plus importante
donc on prend beaucoup moins de risques
que les derniers les derniers nominés et
les derniers louis peut-être sur ce
sujet et on terminera que les deux
dernières questions ensuite sur le
justement les retombées c'est ben là il
ya l'héritage les héritages auprès de
nos jeunes derrière dr les jeux
on a déjà le patrimoine qui existent en
donc en termes d'équipement les gros
équipements saisis aura pas de souci
mais après auprès des maires peut-être
ne met plus une politique sportive au
sein de leur collectivité plus de
créneaux horaires plus d'accessibilité à
la pratique il ya un handicap ou pas
mais derrière c'est vrai c'est
l'héritage les héritages du monde
sportif à travers les jeux de dernière
question
déjà ce qu'on a appris des erreurs de
paris 2012 marie claire je vous regarde
pas ce que vous étiez dans justement
parmi les personnes qui ont milité pour
que je pense qu'on a on a appris de la
candidature de 2008 et de la candidature
de 2012
et je pense qu'on a appris que
voilà aujourd'hui la candidature est
davantage porté par un certain nombre de
sportifs tony estanguet étant le fer de
lance de cette de cette équipe parce
qu'il faut pas oublier que même si
l'ensemble de la population est
complètement derrière cette candidature
c'est pas la population qui va décider
c'est juste 120 membres du cio qui à un
moment donné le jour j à lima vont dire
je vote pour paris est donc tout le
travail à faire
2 voilà pour convaincre ces personnes là
c'est de leur dire que pour le mouvement
olympique pour l'esprit olympique et
pour toutes les valeurs que l'olympisme
et que le cio porte depuis des années
paris est un très bon choix c'est le
travail qui qui qui est en train d'être
fait et on a bon espoir que ce travail
là puissent aboutir de façon très très
favorable pour un pour notre région
puisqu'elle pour la la question oui mais
c'est vrai parce que là on va voter
vendredi qui vient une somme pour la
colline d'elancourt mais on a beau
mettre l'argent en prévision ne s'est
pas parce qu'on aura mis cet argent
qu'on aura les jeux olympiques c'est
bien le travail qui est fait par les
sportifs dans la famille des olympiens
ont entre autres et le comité olympique
et je crois que là on a appris
raison le on doit au nom de notre
population aidée mais ce sont les
sportifs qui font cette candidature
voilà les les sportifs l'ensemble des
fédérations internationales aussi dans
lesquels à sarm de sportifs sont sont
parties prenantes qui qui porte la
parole de la candidature de paris selon
louis radio s'il faut vraiment créé une
effervescence vraiment autour des
régions voient pas mal
d'événements qui sont créés autour des
jeux olympiques par exemple loisirs
saint quentin en yvelines ya eu des
événements avec des jeunes c'est celle
là peut être que repose
fédérer il faut fédérer jusqu'au 13
septembre c'est à dire que tous les
acteurs sont les bienvenus pour soutenir
la candidature alors les des acteurs
c'est moi je pense souvent aux écoles
aux écoles aux lycées au collège même
aux universitaires qui peuvent qui ont
des billes mais ces générations 2024
c'est eux voilà parce que c'est eux qui
regarderont hâter ce qu'ils pratiqueront
aussi en 2001 4 c'est aussi et peut-être
aussi qu'ils iront donc c'est eux qu'il
faut fédérer et convaincre pour
accompagner le mouvement sportif dans
cette candidature ici c'est paris vous
pouvez pousser jusqu'en 2024
je ne pense non alors là avec toutes ont
été si je dois aller jusqu'à jusqu'à une
prochaine pièce ce sera tokyo mais 2024
non jeu si vous avez besoin de moi pour
sur le terrain moi je serais plutôt sur
le terrain c'est en tant qu entraîneur
bénévole ou consultant ou consultant en
tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir
participé à ce débat sur les jeux
olympiques est juste un mot rapidement
en un mot si je vous dis que paris
allait gio paris 2024 ça ressemblera à
quoi en un mot ce sera ce sera là la
fête du sport à paris là là voilà c'est
le monde qui se rassemblera en un mot je
ne sais pas dire l'effervescence j'en ai
un et l'enthousiasmé
j'hésite entre bonheur et aux feux
d'artifice on peut choisir les deux peut
dire aussi sport lumière ça fera un
ville lumière et mélanger sport voilà
j'ai préparé ma petite phrase de fin
voilà autant là autant la mettre merci
michael merci d'avoir été tous les trois
avec nous sur ce sur ce plateau pour ce
débat sur les jeux olympiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]